j'ai bien peur que quelqu'un doit mourir
maintenant non non
[Rires]
le système de sécurité des activités
[Musique]
question subsidiaire
crois-tu que j'ai pu entrer chez toi
avant que tu es réactiver le système de
sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un mort derrière un bar du
centre-ville et voilà compta graisse à
l'hôpital et la pelle venait du
téléphone d'Ember et alors il avait déjà
appelé avec mon numéro avant d'agresser
Tara ou bien c'est juste un truc qui me
passe par la tête c'est toi le tueur et
vous vous étiez où à ce moment là ici
je regarde Netflix ah ouais super ton
alibi mon pote et toi tu étais où je
l'interrogeais ainsi que ses amis au
poste de police ouais je suis venu dès
que j'ai su mais bon Netflix c'est un
bon alibi aussi vous deux vous vous
calmez vous allez mettre plus d'hommes
devant sa porte n'est-ce pas oui et je
peux vous réserver tout un étage mon
adjoint connaît son boulot vous serez
bien protégé comment nous a protégé
jusque là
Samantha allons parler d'or
ravi de vous revoir Cherif adjointe x on
s'est tellement amusé toutes les deux
c'est Cherif x moi aussi je me souviens
de toi et de tous les problèmes que tu
causais à ta famille
ta présence ici nous aide pas alors je
me disais que demain matin avec ton
petit copain vous pourriez repartir au
lieu de perturber le travail de ceux qui
aiment notre communauté
toujours aussi sympathique celle-là dis
donc tout va bien
vous pourriez nous laisser une seconde
il faut que je parle à Tara ramène-toi
Netflix on sort
bonsoir Samantha
Richie ne peut pas décrocher là
il a découvert ce qui arrive à ceux qui
font leur nez dans des affaires qui ne
regardent pas
tu sais quoi à toi de choisir je n'en
tuerai qu'à
lequel des deux tu veux entendre mourir
je
vous offre vraiment tu n'es même pas
capable de sauver ta sœur tu n'as qu'une
chose à dire tu es riche
[Musique]
et je ferai attention à bien toucher
tous les organes que j'ai raté la
dernière fois
c'est ta dernière chance m'en sauver un
choisi
tu veux savoir pourquoi ça c'est
peut-être parce que tu es une sale
égoïste qui n'est même pas capable de
faire un choix pour sauver la vie d'une
personne que tu aimes
peut-être que tu es trop faible pour
cette franchise
vous avez peut-être raison
[Musique]
ça va
je veux pas mourir pas aujourd'hui
on se casse
allez dépêchez-vous
la tête quoi la tête il faut leur tirer
dans la tête sinon il se relève toujours
non revenez on s'en fout
non non non non non non non non non non
non non non non non non non non
c'est parfait elle fait la bringue
qui fait la bringue en pleine vague de
meurtre je laisse tomber le plan non non
vite fait j'en ai pour 5 minutes je
viens avec toi ok si vous croyez que je
vais attendre ici comme but vous êtes
des grandes balades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut comment ça se fait que t'es pas à
l'hôpital tu es sûr que c'est une bonne
idée d'être là j'ai besoin de mon
inhalateur pourquoi où vous voulez aller
d'accord non non
je comprends mais fais gaffe OK
tu crois qu'il est dans ma chambre
ok tout le monde merci d'être
venu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut couper la musique s'il vous
plaît
salut
la génération Z comment ça va ça mets ta
race ce sont toutes les deux fait
agresser par le tueur deux fois et
maintenant elles sont ici ce qui fait de
cette maison une bonne grosse cible
alors si j'étais vous je crois que je
partirai ok j'ai essayé d'être gentil
alors maintenant foutez
le corps vous pouvez me croire
merci les amis